merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics monsieur
Gabriel Attal nous avons une nouvelle
phase de notre gestion des finances
publiques je tiens tout d'abord à saluer
votre initiative renouvelée cette année
encore avec les dialogues de Bercy qui
inclut toutes les sensibilités
parlementaires après le quoi qu'il en
coûte qui a permis de préserver des
centaines de milliers d'entreprises et
d'emplois puis les mesures d'urgence
pour répondre à l'inflation en premier
lieu le bouclier tarifaire qui ont
permis d'atténuer l'effet de la hausse
des prix sur le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens nous devons désormais
accélérer sur la rationalisation des
dépenses publiques et le désendettement
parce qu'une France tropendettée c'est
une France qui abdique de sa
souveraineté et abandonne son avenir
vous avez présenté en fin de semaine un
document sur les plafonds des dépenses
de l'État pour 2024 avec des économies
principalement sur la fin des mesures
d'urgence nous le saluons
mais c'est seuls efforts ne suffiront
hélas pas à rétablir durablement nos
finances publiques un outil essentiel et
la lutte contre la fraude contre toutes
les fraudes c'est nécessaire pour
garantir la justice sociale et en la
matière nous n'avons pas rugir de nos
efforts à ce titre nous travaillons
depuis des mois avec vous monsieur le
ministre sur la fraude à la TVA première
recette pour son montant et donc
première source potentielle de fraude
par des outils simples nous voulons y
répondre efficacement avec un effet avec
un fort effet de levier potentiel et
donc des perspectives de financement
pour nous enjeux d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
entre autres l'adaptation au changement
climatique la santé de nos concitoyens
et l'accompagnement de chacun vers un
logement digne et durable pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre nous préciser où en
est la phase de lancement de la facture
électronique nous entreprises qu'elles
soient grandes ou petites nos
administrations sont-elles prêtes à
faire face à cette nouvelle obligation
je vous remercie